E
THIS TYPE OF CONTENT AND
EVIDENCE AS THEY LEAD INTO THESE
NEXT ROUND OF HEARINGS, WHICH
WILL TAKE PLACE IN SEPTEMBER.
>> RYAN NOBLES, APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
FOR MORE ON MARC SHORT, THE
FEDERAL GRAND JURY, AND WHAT IT
COULD MEAN, WE'RE JOINED BY
JEFFREY TOOBIN.
GREG JACOB, MARC SHORT TESTIFIED
IN FRONT OF A FEDERAL GRAND
JURY.
>> IT'S A BIG DEAL, ESPECIALLY
IN THE BIG PICTURE.
THE MAIN CRITICISM OF THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT SO FAR HAS
BEEN THAT THEY'RE UNDULY FOCUSED
OR EXCLUSIVELY FOCUSED ON THE
SMALL FISH, THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
INSIDE THE CAPITOL, YOU KNOW,
WHO TRESPASSED, WHO COMMITTED
ACTS OF VIOLENCE AND NOT FOCUSED
AT ALL ON THE PEOPLE WHO MAY
HAVE COMMITTED THE LARGER
OFFENSES, THE PEOPLE CLOSEST TO
TRUMP.
THIS SHOWS THAT THEY ARE LOOKING
AT WHAT WAS GOING ON AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
PLUS, YOU KNOW, THE PENCE
OFFICIALS ARE PART OF OR
WITNESSES TO AT LEAST THREE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT AREAS OF
INQUIRY.
ONE IS THE PRESSURE ON MIKE
PENCE TO VIOLATE HIS OATH AND
STOP THE CERTIFICATION OF THE
ELECTION.
THE FAKE ELECTOR SCHEME.
AND THE EFFORT TO CORRUPT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
THEY KNOW ABOUT ALL OF THAT.
SO, THE FACT THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS NOW -- HAS THOSE
PEOPLE IN THE GRAND JURY
SUGGESTS THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
INVESTIGATING.
>> THIS IS A DUMB QUESTION, BUT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, DO THEY
NEED TO RE-INTERVIEW BEFORE A
GRAND JURY EVERYBODY WHO
TESTIFIED BEFORE THE JANUARY 6
COMMITTEE OR THE MAIN PLAYERS?
>> WELL --
>> THEY WON'T JUST TAKE THE
TESTIMONY THAT WAS GIVEN UNDER
OATH BY MARC SHORT, OBVIOUSLY,
TO THE JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE.
>> THEY COULD.
AND THEY COULD JUST USE THAT
TESTIMONY IN THE GRAND JURY.
THE ISSUE WITH THE GRAND JURY IS
AT SOME POINT, PRESUMABLY,
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ASKED TO
ISSUE INDICTMENTS OF SOMEONE.
THEY HAVE TO HAVE EVIDENCE ON
WHICH TO BASE THOSE INDICTMENTS.
YOU KNOW, HEARSAY EVIDENCE IS
ADMISSIBLE IN A GRAND JURY.
SO, THEY COULD GO PLAY THE
VIDEOS OF THE DEPOSITIONS OF --
FROM THE JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE.
BUT PROSECUTORS USUALLY WANT TO
SEE WITNESSES FOR THEMSELVES.
THEY MAY NOT ASK EXACTLY THE
SAME QUESTIONS AS THOSE --
>> WOULD THEY HAVE TO SUBPOENA
MARC SHORT?
>> HE SAID --
>> THEY DID.
>> -- THAT THEY DID.
>> WHAT DOES IT SAY THEY WERE
WILLING TO SUBPOENA SOMEONE AS
FORMERLY HIGH LEVEL AS MARC
SHORT?
>> IT SHOWS THEY'RE SERIOUS.
THIS IS -- THAT'S WHY TODAY IS
SO IMPORTANT, THIS GRAND JURY
TESTIMONY IS SO IMPORTANT,
BECAUSE IT SHOWS THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS NOT JUST FOCUSING
ON THE SMALL FISH.
NOW, WHETHER THERE WILL BE
INDICTMENTS OF PEOPLE UP TO AND
INCLUDING PRESIDENT TRUMP, I
CERTAINLY DON'T KNOW THAT.
BUT THERE CERTAINLY WOULDN'T BE
INDICTMENTS OF THE PEOPLE LIKE
TRUMP IF THESE PEOPLE WERE NOT
IN THE GRAND JURY.
>> YOU DID HERE MERRICK GARLAND
SAYING, YOU KNOW, NO PERSON IS
ABOVE THE LAW.
PG I GUESS YOU COULD LOOK AT
THIS AND SAY THIS PUTS THIS INTO
SHARPER FOCUS.
>> GRAND JURY INVESTIGATIONS
ARE, BY DEFINITION, SECRET.
THE ONLY REASON THIS CAME OUT IS
BECAUSE REPORTERS HAPPENED TO
JUST SEE SHORTCOMING OUT OF THE
COURTHOUSE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHO EXACTLY HAD
TESTIFIED IN THE GRAND JURY.
BUT, YOU KNOW, THIS -- THE FACT
THAT THEY ARE THERE IS A BIG
DEAL.
>> SO, WE DON'T KNOW AND WON'T
KNOW UNTIL EITHER SOMEONE BREAKS
IT OR CHARGES ARE FILED HOW FAR
ADVANCED THEY ARE IN THEIR
INVESTIGATION.
>> NO.
I MEAN, THERE ARE SEVERAL WAYS
YOU CAN FIND OUT.
I MEAN, YOU CAN SEE PEOPLE --
PHYSICALLY SEE THEM GOING IN AND
OUT.
ALL THE REPORTERS KNOW WHICH ARE
THE GRAND JURY ROOMS.
INDIVIDUALS CAN SAY THAT THEY
TESTIFIED, BUT, YOU KNOW,
WHETHER THE GRAND JURY ISSUES AN
INDICTMENT OR NOT, THAT IS
ALMOST NEVER KNOWN UNTIL --
IT
HAPPENS.
>> IF THIS INVESTIGATION
CONTINUES AND THERE'S A NEW
PRESIDENT AND THAT PRESIDENT
APPOINTS A NEW HEAD OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, DOES THE
INVESTIGATION AUTOMATICALLY
CONTINUE?
ZBLIT CERTAINLY DOES NOT
AUTOMATICALLY CONTINUE.
IT CAN CONTINUITY.
THE CUSTOM IN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, ESPECIALLY WITH
CAREER PEOPLE, IS THAT
INVESTIGATIONS CONTINUE FROM ONE
ADMINISTRATION TO THE NEXT.
BUT CERTAINLY THE SENIOR
LEADERSHIP WILL CHANGE.
AND I THINK IF DONALD TRUMP IS
ELECTED PRESIDENT